ladies and gentlemen that's a little too
aggressive
you know ladies
ladies lady i want to get like i want to
come in from here and just kind of
right ladies and gentlemen welcome to
the tim dillon show
we are here two weeks out
before thanksgiving i got fat again i
was
thin on the alex jones podcast i got fat
again at trader joe's
you don't know how it happened it always
sneaks up on you as my boomer father
would say
every time you turn around
he's just talking to him about corona
yeah i was just on a phone and he goes
you know every time you turn around he
just doesn't
fully articulate thoughts anymore he
just goes
every time you turn around you can't get
ahead
they're always they're always coming
after you
i'm not trying to get in any trouble
every time you turn around
he could wake up in the middle of the
night see his wife getting brutally
raped and having a throat cut and he'd
go every time you turn around
every time you turn around
well there goes that youtube
monetization huh
in the first minute i said the r word
not good trader joe's makes you feel fat
because trader joe's you get
aggressively
you get like confidently facts there's a
lot of fat women walking
with their fupas and biden one so it's
[ __ ]
biden bon bon day it's like get the
cakes get the ice cream they're like you
don't tell me
[ __ ] and they got their [ __ ] out and
they're fat
front puss the fupa right yeah so they
got the fupas out and they're like
that's right [ __ ] and then i start to
look at them and i'm like
yes [ __ ] and i start grabbing things
and i start just putting stuff in
the cart and they're putting it and
they're like are you getting that
wine cranberry ticket salad and i'm like
yeah
and everybody's just [ __ ] just
waddling down the rows of trader joe's
like
just putting [ __ ] french vanilla ice
cream in their ass and
because biden won and everybody's like
you don't tell me what's pretty
so i got a little out of control
and i got a loaf of french bread
bread and butter is so good it's one of
the things that's really good you can
just eat it we have whitney webb coming
up by the way it's not all about brad we
do have the great whitney webb
she's on the program and adderall i'm
kidding but she is very
she's very ask her one question she just
goes you know
she's just like well the interesting
thing about the freedom of information
request requested eric schmidt who is
the head of google in the nsa and darpa
and the dea and it's like whoa
smoke a joint before you fire that one
up but she's always got great
information
you know terrifying
interesting it's going to happen these
things are kind of going to happen
probably
you know i mean alex jones was talking
about some of it on rogue and the future
is not going to be human
whatever i can't get makes upset about
that
it's interesting and i'm i'm not
thrilled with it but i can't get too
upset about because i
know that i'm not gonna see a lot of it
probably
you know this you know
yes we're gonna merge with ai at some
point but i won't
they're not gonna merge me with a.i
they're gonna be like you will die on
your own
i'm not wasting anything on you imagine
they
merged right comp with ai it's like
listen like what
like they just called me they're gonna
make me in
with a robot they're gonna make me into
a [ __ ] robot listen to me
i'm gonna be ai arya
he was supposed to come out in december
he just got a promotion at his
job so congratulations to raymond cump
he is a king finally being treated like
a king the creek in the cave
and long island city closed it's where i
really started my comedy career
it was a mexican restaurant did it serve
expired food perhaps
did they know how to melt cheese not
really you'd think that would be a
prerequisite for a mexican restaurant
melting cheese but that's okay it was
about comedy
a lot of great comedians came out of
there not really
but some donald glover went there once
so they they just say
donald glover he was like just stopped
in there once
rebecca trent the owner loved comedy
and we appreciate her she allowed
comedians to go in there and
get better at comedy and then the big
brouhaha
happened when the leaders of skanks
podcast my friends louis jay gomez dave
smith big j
okerson booked milo yiannopoulos to
appear on the program
uh last year and the comedy community in
new york
threw a fit and they threw this woman
rebecca trent
under the bus big time now this woman
and i knew her
she had thanksgivings every year and
christmases for people that did not
have the money to fly home to their
families comics didn't move to new york
city or people that just didn't have
families
to fly home to she had christmases for
them
she raised money for several comics that
had cancer
she allowed certain comics to like
almost basically
live at the creek in the cave that
didn't have a place to live
and then everybody decided that all of
that
didn't really mean that she wasn't a
nazi
they went right at her they said well
this woman yes she's fed us
and let us stay here and
given us a place to do comedy but a
podcast at her venue
booked a gay conservative troll
so this woman as you know she's a part
of the german bund
i guess i don't know but
it was a split in the comedy community
um between
the comics that were like hey respect
the right of artists to do whatever they
want and the comics that were like she's
a
nazi and i don't like
nazis nazis are bad
so there was that very reasonable
rational discourse
that was had between people that were
like well
we're respecting the right of a podcast
to have on a guest that is controversial
and then on the other side people that
were like are you gonna put
people in gas chambers hitler
you're like well no it was just gonna
let a guy who lost his entire career
appear
in the basement of a mexican restaurant
on the legion of skanks podcast
uh a guy who had lost a book deal when
it lost all the spots on fox news he
would have imagined that
this would be the kind of justice you
people wanted right i mean
he's literally sitting there as they fry
[ __ ] tortillas
and he's got to make a point about
globalism
okay while he he has to step on
guacamole
he's a nazi and she's a nazi and you're
a nazi
that's gonna be the musical about this
era nazis here
nazis there nazis everywhere
these people think it's like the sound
of music except in that era there were
actual
nazis everywhere now it's like
everybody's
like so she never fully recovered from
that her
image in the community not to people
like me
we dig her but the looney tunes now the
problem is when you own a comedy venue
many of the people that that go there
are looney tunes
they're maniacal so when you
uh fall on the wrong side of crazy town
those people are angry at you
and that hurts your business because
they
say that you are supporting hate speech
and they had anthony kumia on and people
went nuts about
that and
unfortunately this woman never and she
called me and i spoke to her about it
and i said listen lewis called me i
remember i was outside of my apartment
at queen's lewis goes is this guy really
that bad is milo that bad i go
i don't really think it's it's
that big of a deal but i said then again
you're asking me but i
i i don't think it's that big of a deal
um that's me but
she called me and she goes what am i
doing am i doing the right thing here i
said i think you are
i don't think it will end with milo
yiannopoulos i think if you would allow
um people to shut down
a controversial guest on a podcast this
doesn't stop
with that guy it just won't
and and she you know
agreed with me and now her business is
closed
that's it but i think it was a it's the
corona lockdown
but part of it is that as a mind virus
that's eating the minds of many people
that you knew
and that you were friends with and uh
biden's win will not
cure them by the way ah it will not cure
them
and you know i feel bad for her because
i think that was this weird turning
point where
the people that she had supported and
the people that she had
also just learned how to melt cheese but
the people that she had supported
and the and the people
that she had gone to bat for did not
really go to bat for her
i did i was on social media
you know bringing it up saying this
woman all she's done is trying to help
comedians but
what are you going to do you know i'm
trying to throw this friends giving we
got to wait till monday and see if
newsom is going to come out with more
regulations is newsome going to shut us
down
i got covert tests for people we're
doing it outside we got heat lamps
i just don't know i don't know
i'm waiting for the for the other shoe
to drop
i'm waiting for newsome on monday
morning i could have it in
in deference well no that's not the
right word right
you could have what i said indeference
that means in support of
oh right right right in spite of it
newsom there you go i could have it in
spite of newsome
and just say [ __ ] him and i could get
arrested
out of friendsgiving
i'm just gonna have a wheel of pasta
where they make the you know they make
the
pasta in the wheel i can't have that now
on my own
what if they don't have it and i don't
cancel the caterers and then they show
up and i'm just sitting there
and i go toss it again i've eaten like
three they're like
this is unhealthy i'm like toss it again
please
i don't know it's gonna be like that
scene monty python at the end where that
guy's just eating and eating
and blowing up but the menu's great i
mean we got a menu of food here you
don't even
i mean you go [ __ ] your mother
we got maniscalco's guy you know the guy
that sebastian menescalcon makes
eggplant with
i love sebastian he's a he's levity in a
time where
everyone's talking about corona and the
civil war and sebastian's you know
yeah you know sometimes
you know you gotta have a [ __ ] sauce
you know
are you embarrassed with the ragu and
the prego
you take the you take the [ __ ] onion
and the garlic
and you put it you know and outside just
you know just bombs going on but you
need you need levity you need people to
focus on tomato sauce and garlic and
stuff
but you do not saying anything negative
i believe you do i believe that you
can't have everyone be me
yeah somebody's got to come in there and
go
you ever had the county almond cookie
arana
who's this guy george floyd what are
people doing
why is everybody screaming
what is everybody screaming about
who brianna taylor what's brianna's you
mean brianni the suits
i love those they're suits they fit
their custom suits brianne
what are we done what are we doing
what are we doing here
you need that you need somebody to come
in and go let's talk about pine nuts
let's talk it's true yes i know let's
talk about pesto now yeah
i can't be yelling all the goddamn time
about nazis and people trying to kill
you and transhumanism and
veal you need somebody to come in
so i got his guy who's gonna be [ __ ]
doing real
great food tossing you know pasta in a
thing and
i just don't know if we're gonna [ __ ]
if gavin newsom's gonna shut it down
because you know he's a miserable prick
i'm kidding i know that there's health
concerns
but let it happen
what if there was a party called the let
it happen like the like a movement
called let it happen
let it rip let corona rip
be stronger on the other side by the way
new york city is just
the kids got to go back from school on
monday yeah how great is that you
you're your disgusting children are back
in your house
you got rid of them and you sent them
into the new york city public school
system
to learn how to [ __ ] and do drugs and
then you get them back in the house on
monday
you got to deal with that how was school
good we learned how to put on condoms
great
well welcome back you could go put one
on in your room
try i mean i don't know what the plan is
here but i just
you know at a certain point now i don't
want to
do the police take me out of my own home
as i'm like holding a cheese wheel of
pasta
is that what has to happen for freedom
i mean yes well yes do i have to
fight a cop in the doorway of my house
with pumpkin ravioli we're having
pumpkin ravioli
with the brown butter sauce and sage
oh i mean
do i have to get shot by a cop
in the doorway to my house because i
just want to have a little dinner party
everybody's made as covered in l.a by
the way yeah it was mermaid
has covered my maid has coven
so they lock her in a room they're like
our mate you know i was in the hamptons
andrew khan's brothers like the maid had
kovitz we just made her quarantine you
know
they just locked her in a room and
they're like we brought her food it's
very nice
i of course had no way to authenticate
if they really brought her food right
and what kind of food they brought her
right
you know they brought her cereal with
water
you know they probably googled the the
least amount of food she could survive
on
and brought it to her okay the maid has
covered you know the day she recovered
from kova they're like let's go
the day she tested negative she's like
i'm still kind of a little
let's go now vacation's over
she's like in the room can't breathe
like
some [ __ ] in the hamptons like hey hey
hey
hey okay listen to me
vacation is juanita
vacation is over you've taken some
personal time
and we appreciate that okay josefina
but now it is time to come out here and
do your work
maybe it all evens out maybe when we all
die the women from the hamptons are on
their knees scrubbing
be great wouldn't that be great who
knows i don't know if that's the case
i'm unaware of what happens but i think
that
there's very little chance that that's
going to happen very little chance
but it would be nice what if we did like
uh what if we wrote a show about maids
just infecting their
host families with covid you know
just really trying to infect the host
families with covet
great you know yeah
what was that show wasn't there a show
about maids
i don't know desperate housewives and
the maids were featured prominently
devious maids yeah devious maids except
they are giving the families covert
i'm going to give that [ __ ] covet
i hope she gets coffin i'm going to
lick every single class and when she has
her pinot grigio i hope she gets carved
i'm just hoping i don't have to have a
standoff with the lapd
over this cheese wheel and i'm
anticipating that could happen
because i'm standing up for the freedom
of you and your family to have a cheese
wheel
you want to feed youtubers out of a
cheese wheel well guess what
i'm standing up for your right to do
that
okay i know no one's i guarantee all the
people i want to come are not going to
come
and it's just going to be me this kid
and i'm not going to say who but there's
going to be people there that you know
spends a lot of money on catering
it's not exactly gonna be the a-list
let's just say that
there'll be a lot of people there that
the you know best thing that happened to
them would be kovan
it's just let's just say that there's
gonna be a lot of there's going to be a
lot of problems
i'm hoping not i'm hoping everything
works out and everybody comes you get
some good interesting people there
when you've had the same car insurance
or homeowners insurance for years you
kind of get trapped into paying your
premiums and not thinking about it it
makes it really easy to overpay
trust me you don't even realize it okay
i've had my
car insurance forever and i don't even
think about it i just pay it then i go
this is too much
money hello
i say that sometimes seeing about
seeing see about getting a lower rate
for the exact same coverage you have
thanks to gabby
gabby takes the pain of shopping for
insurance by giving you an apples to
apples
comparison of your current coverage with
40 of the top insurers providers
like progressive nationwide and
travelers
just link your current insurance account
and in minutes you'll be able to see
quotes for the exact same coverage you
currently have
do you pay a lot for coverage way too
much
gabby customers save 825 per year on
average
if they can't find you savings like they
did for me they'll let you know so you
can relax knowing you have the best rate
out there
just link your current insurance account
and in just minutes you'll be able to
see quotes
for the exact same coverage you
currently have
it's totally free to check your rate and
there's no obligation take a few minutes
right now and stop overpaying on your
car and home insurance go to gabby.com
tim dillon that's gabby
g-a-b-i dot com slash tim dillon g-a-b-i
slash tim dillon and my grandfather
always said this
you're not a real driver until you get
in your first accident
ben you like to booze it up
right you're a big drunk mm-hmm yep
that's me you you how long has it been
since you've had a drink
oh man i'm two and a half years sober
now
yeah congrats thanks you know how long i
am
uh 10. right thank you
10 11 years sobriety
and i uh and i focused mainly
on my physical and emotional health yeah
in those 10 years
by becoming a clown who entertains
people
about the dark things that we all must
go through
but when you're boozing it up you booze
bag
what a great term nobody uses anymore
you bit you
yo booze bang
wellness is important don't you think
yes
isn't it important to be well very
wellness people see me they don't always
think
wellness i'm red i'm yelling but
i am well you know why i do no days
wasted when i get
[ __ ] up drunk piss myself
[ __ ] myself fall on the floor wake up
bloody
doesn't matter because i use no days
wasted it's here to help you maximize
life's moments
the hm detox is a vitamin for people who
like to enjoy their drinks tens of
thousands of people are using dhm detox
as their drinking buddy enjoy your
drinks and forget the sunday scaries
and feeling like garbage take two
capsules after your first couple of
drinks and it goes to work it helps
boost your body's natural response
to alcohol and it helps you break down
the toxins
i mean the other night i got shellacked
yeah i went to the cheesecake factory
and started doing
shots and it got political and it got
nasty i mean i was [ __ ] wasted
i remember one time i grabbed the busboy
and i bit his ear
now i had taken a dhm deduct
okay now i when i bit the bus but i
didn't realize if i bit his ear
and i i didn't let go i it was pooling
with
blood and i just spit blood
like a dragon i went game of thrones and
i was
spitting blood in the cheesecake factory
and i
chewed some of his ear and i was
arrested and taken in but i blacked out
i don't remember any of that but i woke
up and i felt great
because i took no days wasted do you
understand
yes i've got you 20 off your first order
and free shipping in the us
just head over to no days wasted dot co
slash tim that's no days wasted
that's yo slash jim go and buy this
folks support the show don't start with
me
don't start with me everybody's got a
big drunk in their life
give this to them it's a great stocking
stuffer
it's a great way to say somebody hey
we're not gonna stop you from drinking
but at least you could wake up and not
be wasted
parties are weird i've i've never really
thrown a party
i've really never thrown apart it's like
the first thing i'm trying to do
so i thought it'd be fun to do i'm
moving into a new thing i thought it'd
be cool
you know i but i've never really i would
go and attend parties but i never really
threw up actual party with like food and
[ __ ] like that i've never done that
have you ever done that no never well of
course not
but your wedding was going to be the
first part of you through
pretty much and weren't you just going
to get like a tot like troughs of food
and few people like pigs and stuff
that's what you were going to do what
were you going to do like barbecue in
texas was going to be fun
outside austin do like line dancing and
stuff yeah square dancing
square dancing and line dancing yeah
that's fun huh but weren't you gonna
have a taco truck
no no no no you would do a taco truck no
i wasn't gonna do a taco truck
are you gonna still have a wedding yeah
more like a celebration in april
if things are still not closed right so
you could do a celebration in april yeah
yeah
down in austin i'm booked unfortunately
i'll let you know the dates so you can i
didn't want to go
listen ben's wife hates me so i didn't
want to go unless she does
i didn't want to go and disturb your
wedding by being there
you know what i mean so that's why i
didn't want to go i told you i was
booked but i wasn't really booked
did you know when i told you that i was
booked i wasn't really bugged no you did
have a date unless you made a fake date
on your way i made a fake date
did you really i did make a fake date
i'd say i'd steinberg do it
with like a fake link and everything i
don't know how
in-depth he got he's a demon he's a
demon from hell
but no i i didn't want to go and ruin
your wedding
well you're invited to the celebration
well i don't believe that but that's
very sweet of you
ben like i don't know you're you're
family super christian i didn't want to
my mom watches the show now oh she
watched all your rogan appearances too
well good and she's buying a sauna this
week because she's been watching so much
rogan
also okay well that may not be the best
i don't know that's
phenomenal but i i will be there this
time
i will be there i will be there this
time i will be there this time i'm very
i'm very excited
about it get a nice bathtub of pulled
pork
but my event which will be a little bit
more
uh you know i will probably be a
disaster
i've invited some fatties and what i'm
concerned with is
fat people can get violent
truly yeah they can get truly violent
yes
and i've invited some real houses
to the party i mean some big
thick and and i'm just hoping that
the spacing is is good because that it's
not that big
what are you laughing about there are
some yeah there's some big people coming
there's some there's some people that
are large and in charge
yeah if they come some of them may not
you know they might do what i did with
ben's wedding where you go now
and then you send a gift and i sent a
beautiful gift yes you did
this is our joke i didn't send a gift
because i believe if i don't go i don't
give you a gift
i don't give you a gift if i'm not there
i mean that's just
the reality you know what i mean
you know i'm not gonna go to dan's
wedding he's got a few more days left
a few more days left of this before he's
out of here we block him
you know it's just what happens ben's
the only one that's going to stick
around because ben
understands that uh without him i would
just be committing acts of domestic
terrorism
i said that to the girl at whitney's the
girl from cheer you know this this
this white trash rat that whitney had in
her house
what do you think i care you know this
tattooed animal whitney thinks cheer
when he coming sees tears like a big
can you shut to stop it when he just
likes poor people and she likes to play
with them like play-doh
so she likes to
she likes to bring them in her hot tub
and she's like
wouldn't it be fun if one day you
weren't desperate
maybe that would be fun huh do you think
that would be
fun i don't worry about
anything ever but i bet you do
and i bet the nights are cold are they
cold
are they cold we'll get in the hot tub
and so she has this meth head in her hot
tub who's a cheerleader which
come on like competitive cheerleading in
texas like i give a [ __ ]
so i woke it's supposedly it's the most
watched show on netflix i don't give a
[ __ ] everything on netflix suck
the queen's gambit sucks it sucks it's
bad everything's bad now
it's not good
the chest thing they should make is when
bobby fischer went nuts and went into
jews
we have a fun chess story the day of 9
bobby fischer called the radio station
she had gone over the juice
why are we that's a fun chess story of
how
he went to there how he became that
that's a fun chess story
not [ __ ] hey this [ __ ] likes doing
taking pills and chess who cares
so nothing's good i don't care if it's
the most watched show on netflix
what's the second most watched the ranch
with ashton kutcher and that other guy
the most watched show on netflix means
[ __ ] to me
i don't care what people do some idiot
who's got guy swimming around in a
bathtub a sweet tea
and [ __ ] it just longs for a time
that she could
see your own foot is watching people do
tumble salts that is impressed
so i care i think not i think not oh
they have a lot of followers on
instagram
i want less followers i want less
followers
because i don't want to feel guilty
because the end of this is heaven's gate
call we go to the hillbob comet and
drink
poison i will get all of you to drink
poison
my point is this i go over to the house
and there's this girl who's this i'm
sure she's sweet
she's with some other kid they're all
tattooed they're in decent shape i'm
unimpressed
i'm there because i want food that
whitney will purchase
which i don't i always offer to buy but
she buys and i think that's a better
system
so they're in the hot tub and i go
and and one girl says to me and she goes
i really lucked out with my manager
because i lucked out with my manager
because she's like i want to build
businesses around my passions and not
just do random brand deals
she goes i also really am looking for
guidance
i want people to guide me and steer me
in a direction but i don't want to be
controlled i just want guidance
and she goes what would you like to do i
was returning and she was in the hot tub
i looked at her i said
i want to commit an act of domestic
terrorism
do you understand so i'm looking for
someone to help build a terrorist
network around my passions do you
understand
and not just random brand deals
i want guidance imagine somebody in al
qaeda being like
what i like about this organization is
that i don't feel controlled but i'm
given guidance
given guidance by the saudis the c.i.a
bin laden
the girl kind of laughed
cheer no one cares no one gives a [ __ ]
about your shitty lives
i don't care that they put them on
netflix i don't care that uh
uh you know it's a big deal on netflix
because uh there's so much heart these
kids have so much are you they're on
meth one of them went away for cp
yeah child porn yeah he's got a lot of
heart
he's got too much heart he's good with
cb
stop glorifying these shitty things that
no one cares about
i'm a competitive cheerleader stop
get grow up and graduate school yeah and
go work at the dairy queen
and make the blizzard good
let's not call it cheer let's call it
people who will make blizzards in five
years
on netflix future blizzard makers of
america
on netflix and there's nothing wrong
with that i respect the blizzard we
might get one later
but whitney's got them over you know and
whitney's like show me your scars show
me the scars of your
of your poverty when he's pretending we
just got like nail people coming in
whitney's like whitney's like this these
are the people that do the nails for uh
there's cardi b right yeah cardi b these
are the people that do the nails
for cardi b literally as she said that
i'm at her table
and i go like this i go is is there
two marinara sauces or one
i wanted two
and these kids like what i just want to
build businesses around my passions
like what meth
pull her up get the girl up that was on
there she did drugs
that's all right she's a good person we
respect her yes
what did she do she did some crank go to
the mug shot what did she do
there you go what'd she do she's a
little crank
there's nothing wrong with that i
respect that
oh possession of marijuana i think oh
marijuana all right
well i feel bad now stupid
what else i thought of something good i
thought it was something good
well there's a cp guy as well well he
got a cp
who cares let her smoke
he was over too he's he's like a weird
vegan and the other guy was a
pescetarian
and the other guy goes like this the
other guy goes yeah i'm a pescetarian
what kind of weirdo only eats fish i'm
like i love fish but if you're going to
take a moral stand
it's ridiculous
that is a lot of weed what you have
a usable quantity in the amount of two
ounces or less
yeah that's not a lot not for these
people
they just smoke weed and go to
whataburger
and we gotta watch it like it's
fascinating because they can do a
somersault
these kids have so much heart
you get this out of here that's cp on
the bottom there he is this guy yeah ecp
he was the fun one
he was the fun one he was the star of
the show
cheer
give me a c give me a p
give me a c give me a pee
cp
i gotta i gotta sit there and when he's
like you should do a
dance with them it'll be the most shared
video on your instagram i'm like i don't
want to show them up
because number one i'm a better dancer
than they are
here's the reality i'm a professional
dancer i've been schooled in tap
dance ballet hip hop
hip hop jazz jazz is
like you know jazz but hip hop
is is where a bunch of white kids in the
suburbs
have like inflatable boom boxes and
they're like yo yo yo
and they do hip hip-hop like this
but you're a fat white woman being like
yeah like put on like run dmc
and they do hip-hop i've schooled in all
these um dances
i don't do as much gymnastics to say do
but i'm a better dancer modern dance
uh irish tip dance i'm a better
dancer so i didn't want to i don't want
to embarrass them with
my ability to dance there was a dance
teacher i went to the school called
legs and rockville center i like to say
that uh because i want people's real
lives to be hurt
and i'm kidding but it was it was it was
they're
good people the woman who i'm talking
about is clearly dead i'm not going to
say her name okay
her name was cece and she was a dance
teacher who always showed up drunk
and she was a bomb-ass dancer though and
i was like you know i was like
like nine and like like just trying to
get fat and then me and this other kid
used to compete this kid george
and my dad my dad of course when you
want a son you want like a heterosexual
son that you can like
he's like on the baseball field like
killing it my dad was a great baseball
player his little kid
but instead he got this like me with
like a boombox and like you know like
hey mr dj i'm the only kid that i could
the only
competition my father could get involved
with is that we both hated this
fat kid george who was also another
dancer and my dad was like george looks
like an italian baker i was like yeah
[ __ ] george you know we all hated george
um and then cece was this our hip-hop
teacher and she used to come in drunk
all the time
just [ __ ] drunk like she'd booze it
up on the train from the city
and then she would just be like bat she
used to say bat ball time she go
back back like she just woke up your
face back
yeah i don't know it was gunshots
she was drunk and like she'd put like
the music on like we can't play any damn
music right
but it'd be funny she'd be like she's
like stop she'd keep turning the stair
off and she'd be like
which meant you're not doing good which
is the thing whitney does in her dumb
show she goes bet that that
and it's not a dumb show it's a great
show it's the greatest podcast has ever
been but the point is this i love her
the point is this i call every i call
everything dumb cheer is
great everything's great and uh so this
cece who was drunk all the time used to
always be like
when somebody would [ __ ] up the steps
she was like
and and people would be like and she
sometimes she'd stand in your face and
go
and then the parents was like a
well-to-do area the parents were like
weirded out by this they'd be like why
is she
doing this and she just she'd be like
and then she would just start like
but she was a [ __ ] good dancer like
you would imagine like she grew up in
probably some not good situation where
she would just
[ __ ] start busting a move yeah you
know
but uh she had she was go to go to legs
see if she's still working she's not
we had a lot of fun teachers there what
would i type in legs like dance yeah
legs dance
rock who's still over there
yeah go to that go to that go to staff
go to staff
faculties will do it
wow so diana still works there wow
she's got to be old as [ __ ] but no cece
yeah cece was a [ __ ] gangster
you wouldn't even know what you did
wrong she would just stop the music oh
you didn't go once and then she would do
it the right way and he'd be like
[ __ ] that's the way to do it she'd be
like bat like she didn't have the power
of language right
you know and then the people would be
like this is very strange
and then you would could you just spit
booze you get in your face spit booze
and stuff
but she was a dancer she was a real
hip-hop dancer they probably hired her
she they found her like some bodega just
like dancing outside
yeah and the lady all in the place was
like why don't you come we have a lovely
dance school in long island and all of
our kids love hip-hop yo daddy g
so why don't you come here and tell
everyone how to be an og
gangster like yourself
teach everybody how to be a gangster
like yourself and she's like
and you just shop so shit-faced
but she was a [ __ ] gangster i wonder
if we could find her we're never going
to be able to find her
can't find her we can try try cc dance
and then legs yeah like that i don't
know how to spell cc
oh wait hold on i feel like that's her
uh
i don't know if that's her street name
no it's not cece peniston
it might be her street name yeah maybe i
don't want to call out her whole
government
bat
we should call can we call legs are they
open right now
let's see
let's call legs right now please and
find out what happened to cece i'm very
i'm very concerned
call them right now call them right now
please thank you call them right now
where is cece what is she doing
hi i'm the only famous person that's
ever went to your school i'm kidding i'm
not famous but
i'm doing better than these other
[ __ ] i'm doing better than fat george
my dad was like he looks like a baker
i'm like we're all [ __ ] just so
you know i know you're having fun being
competitive but we're all [ __ ] here
sorry that's the name of my new show
coming out on cbs we're all [ __ ] here
it's a bagel shop where just a bunch of
guys hang out
can you get me on the phone with these
people please
she would just go like this too she nah
nah
did you say that i'd be like i tried to
do it the way you wanted you did nah
nah call's not going through right now
why isn't it going through
i hear it no i went to oh okay
well that's [ __ ] up right to voicemail
whitney webb is coming up whitney webb
is a journalist
writer interesting woman
we love having her on we just had to
have a little fun first as we always do
we gotta have a little fun here first
and then uh thanks everybody who signed
up for the patreon we really appreciate
that
very most people don't know about my
career as a dancer no
and it's it was a great career
why do you why do you not why do you not
understand that
i was remembering all the things you've
been a swimmer a dancer
an actor correct yeah did you not want
me going to your wedding because you
thought i would
i would be a better dancer than everyone
is that why you didn't want me to go to
the wedding
it hurt me greatly ben did not want me
in his wedding
but that's okay
ben was going to have one of the door
guys at the comedy store say the vows
it's a joke whatever happened to the
door guys the comedy store are they all
dead
they got furloughed so they're just all
unemployed now
um a lot of them moved home
you know maybe they should go teach
hip-hop dance
on long island one of madonna's backup
dancers
was it legs uh he taught a class there
oh
wow yeah slam
his name was slam yeah he's in her
documentary truth or dare
whitney webb is coming up and we did
would have been an hour with her about
an hour to an hour with whitney and it's
good she's got some good stuff
you know what's coming up man she goes a
lot into the coveted vaccine she talks a
little bit about the election what's
going on
you know there's just a lot going on
here kids and you better get ready
better get ready my dad calls me because
it's just
going to be me and my wife and her
daughter for thanksgiving this year no
luck are you coming or are you what are
you doing for thanksgiving
you know it's like it's just going to be
us three and you know
we'll just we'll see what happens every
time you turn around
every time you turn around you just it's
something else this
other one this is other big one
something else
every time you turn around it's
she's getting her head it's just two
guys like bashing her head into the
uh the counter the dining room
my father just looks his blood
splattered on his face he goes
every time you turn around it's
something else
whitney webb expressvpn
you need your privacy
no one cares what you watch the
government can't see what you watch the
government the government
the government can't see what you watch
you can go and watch japanese netflix
you can watch icelandic whatever
but there's a lot of stuff going on
there's surveillance capitalism we just
did all episode about it with whitney
you get it just get to get the virtual
private network don't start with me
please
you need it and get it for your family
it's private and it's virtual you don't
even
you don't have to go to home depot or
lowe's
what's your favorite thing about it that
it protects me from being
like spied on no one i can change my ip
address i can change my location
all these things are important and if
you change your location then you can
you know
watch stuff and have you ever gone to
youtube and it says can't watch video in
your country
yeah it's not available in your country
right right so then you just do your vpn
now i'm in the uk
so you can get things that aren't
available
in your country
you can watch all kinds of things yeah
yeah
expressvpn.com tim dillon
that's e-x-p-r-e-s
tim dylan you get three extra bites
of expressvpn for free you get three
extra amounts of expressvpn for free
it's a pill for your dick it makes you
dick hard it has the same active
ingredients
as the other big boys but it's cheaper
it's chewable
it ships right to your door no doctor
visits it's not annoying it's really
easy a couple of questions online
see if it's right for you it comes in
discreet packaging right to your door i
mean folks
what are you doing here i don't
understand i don't understand
why you wouldn't get this bill all it
can do is help you
it's made in usa it's prescribed online
by licensed physicians
so you don't have to go to the doctor
wait in line it's even cheaper than a
pharmacy
and they prepare and ship it right to
you in a discrete package no
awkwardness you don't need to leave the
house
you don't need to leave your house which
is great because
it's a quarantine
i want to sing it's a quarantine i can't
really say i can't hear
i can't do it damn it
blue chew it's for you it's for your
your dung it's for the hard
it's for the hog
it's for the hunk there should be a two
blue balls and a penis that should be
their logo yeah
i like that it's sponsored by bluetooth
the episode
it brings you the first chewable with
the same fda approved ingredients as
viagra and cialis how cool is that
awesome how cool is that it's cheap it's
fun
it's fun so go to bluee2.com promo code
td to try it free that's b
l u e c h e w dot com promo code td to
try it free
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show we have returning favorite
fan favorite
one of my favorites whitney webb
independent journalist go and support
her right now
at patreonwhitneywebmpn
uh which stands for mintpress news which
she quit but that's still her name on
patreon
she also has a channel on rockfin which
is a youtube
alternative that monetizes she can make
a little bit
of money there she's also got a book
coming out about
jeffrey epstein and this sordid affair
um and we we have her on today because
so much is going on
and uh we just had a presidential
election we think
and we wanted to know what what is your
take on these voting irregularities
is there anything there
well i think the election is a total um
mess and i think you know in terms of um
what is is going on right now in the us
in terms of the election i think
basically there's a situation that's
being engineered where
we're having where they want one side to
accuse the other side of orchestrating a
coup
and have the other side accuse their
opponents i guess of of doing the same
thing so basically republicans accusing
democrats of a coup and democrats
accusing republicans of a coup
leading towards this sort of what i
would argue were sort of the foundations
of what
could become a sort of an engineered
civil war type scenario
so i do think there are some sort of
issues with the election system
but oddly enough a lot of people on in
the trump circuit aren't really focusing
on what i think a lot of the issues
um are you know there's a lot of
emphasis on voter fraud as opposed to
election fraud and i think a lot of the
causes for concern have to do with um
the increasing control of silicon valley
in the election system
and also the fusion really of silicon
valley with the federal government
and uh silicon valley of course most of
those billionaires were backing biden
by a significant degree but they also
you know donate to republicans but they
don't signif
significantly more uh to democrats and
actually uh
the dnc a lot of their top tech
officials
like their chief technology officer
their chief security officer come from
places like facebook or twitter
and uh facebook and twitter and google
also were part of the operations
uh center for the election run by dhs
um would they i don't think they
honestly should have been there
because they're they're very politicized
entities right but in terms of like what
was going on in specific claims i mean
there's a lot of accusations being
you know thrown around so i'm just
trying to speak in general terms right
because there's a lot of different
things that different people have been
pointing to but i definitely think
there's just a lot of
a lot of efforts to get people really
divided
um right now as we go into the so-called
dark winter that we've been hearing a
lot about
and trying to keep uh you know people
mad at their neighbors for having
the lawn sign of the other uh opponent
or another political candidate instead
of being you know paying attention to a
lot of these
billionaire groups like you know the
world economic forum
or some of these silicon valley
billionaires and whatever that
definitely have agendas that no one
supports or most americans
now what about the machines the the
voting machines there there's a company
and i forget the name of the company but
you're going to know
and they are they have a lot of
a lot of the voting machines are are
this company and supposedly
trump is now tweeting about them saying
that they're an issue because they
switched
a half a million votes in michigan uh
from biden to trump but they caught that
glitch
but he's wondering about what glitches
maybe weren't caught do you know the
name of these machines my producer's
looking it up or the names of the
company
uh uh yeah yeah it should be dominion
dominion correct is the main one but
they're also
they also run software tied to another
company called smartmatic which is also
another big uh
voting electronic voting machine company
but it's worth pointing out
in pretty much every election since
these machines have been introduced
there's been security concerns with them
that really neither party has wanted to
address
and i would definitely argue that you
know elections in the us have been
manipulated
by both parties uh over the past 20
years on
on several occasions sometimes um you
know different parties have different
preferred tactics of how they either
want to suppress the vote or manipulate
the vote but you know
i don't think either party or either you
know republicans or democrats their
establishment wings anyway
have really any interest in addressing a
lot of these core issues
and honestly what i'm more concerned
about um is
this push that we're seeing to implement
a new
software created by microsoft in the in
the military contractor called election
guard
that they're saying is now going to be
the the software on
most voting machines by the next
presidential election
so you know no one's talking about those
sort of issues right
uh we're talking about what is that
software going to be
well it's already out it's called
election guard and it was developed by
co-developed by microsoft and a company
called goloy whose only investor is the
pentagon they do
work for darpa um lovely
yes yes so they want to protect our
elections and that you know the more
they
uh promote these concerns about foreign
interference um
and fraud and things like that the more
microsoft is able to pitch and say this
is the solution
and the guy that's in charge of cyber
security for the elections and all
critical infrastructure kris krebs of
dhs's cisa
is the former uh vp for microsoft who's
been lobbying election guard this whole
time
and he's been in charge of uh protecting
elections uh
this cycle and he you know uh i would
argue that's sort of a conflict of
interest he's been lobbying for election
guard this whole time
so what you were really what you were
doing is such a great job of kind of
just
really charting at you know the course
here
of of of the beginning of the
technocracy
like this is the beginning of how
silicon valley comes to
own all aspects of american life
yeah yeah that seems to be what this is
from uh from automobiles to homes to
shopping to what you searched for on the
internet
to your emails to your cell phone to the
car
the services you use to get around uh
your credit score
uh any interactions you have with the
police whether you're protesting or not
anything you think or feel any business
uh
any anything silicon valley is now going
to control
every aspect of american life
and we're seeing that and they're in
kind of inflating
whether it's coronavirus or this
election
they're just saying listen these
problems are much worse than you think
and the only way we can solve them
is by instituting these new regulations
and with software that we provide and
we're gonna have to put it everywhere
and you're gonna have to use it or die
yeah no i would definitely agree with
that and something that really needs to
be
focused on i think by by people more
that hasn't been getting enough
attention is that we have gotten to a
point where we cannot separate silicon
valley from the state anymore they've
essentially fused and this is
hugely dangerous uh to the future of the
country
uh you could argue that the line between
silicon valley and the state was always
blurry because a lot of these big
silicon valley companies like google for
example
um originally received funding from
groups like the cia's inquitel
for example which obviously comes with
some sort of strings attached down the
line right
right but what we're seeing today is
that you know microsoft for example
which produces election guard you know
they're a major us government contractor
so is google
so is palantir um a lot of these
companies contract and have conflicts of
interest with the state
uh and then you know you look like i
mentioned earlier with the democratic
party specifically you have a lot of
people
in prominent positions at the dnc being
former chief
executives for a lot of these uh silicon
valley companies
um and then you have people like eric
schmidt the former ceo of google
basically uh running the whole
modernization effort at the pentagon
right now and for the national security
state more broadly including the
intelligence community
um you know he's wielding way too much
power he's also uh potentially an abided
administration been fielded to
head a new industry task force uh
which is very alarming because of what
he envisions for the future of the
united states being a largely um
you know automated economy where very
few people have jobs
uh and most work is done by artificial
intelligence or
robots and what's really concerning is
that a lot of people in the us
government are now on board with that
because there's this whole again it
doesn't get a lot of attention but
there's this sort of ai
arms race i guess you could say between
the us
and china and people like eric schmidt
and silicon valley and people in the
military say that it's essential for the
u.s
if the u.s is to remain number one in
terms of military hegemony and economic
hegemony
that we have to have better ai than
china and the only way to do that is to
extract more data
per citizen than china does because
china has an advantage of a larger
population
uh more developed smart city mega city
functionality
uh more people have smartphones so they
can get you know a lot of
more data than people are getting than
the us government right now
or these silicon valley companies can
extract per person in the u.s
so the idea is to get a lot of these uh
smart cities uh
going which have you know basically
smart cities are just full of all these
sensors that constantly
pull in more and more data and um to
basically advance what's often referred
to as the fourth industrial revolution
in the united states to
an extent far beyond uh what
probably most americans want and a lot
of this is being done under the guise of
combating
uh coronavirus uh know basically
implementing a lot of these
humanless technologies saying it's oh
it's it's going to keep us safer but
really
you know a lot of these people wanted to
do this uh well in advance i mean plans
for this go back to 2018
what kind of data are they harvesting in
a smart city would you imagine what kind
of data
are they mining in a smart city
well so basically in smart cities you
have you know sensors basically on
everything it's the internet of things
so you know street lamps have sensors
and and
uh the sewers and all of this stuff
every every aspect of infrastructure has
some sort of sensor tied to it
uh your kitchen appliances all this
stuff it's all supposed to be connected
to the so-called internet of things
and that creates an in basically a
constant supply i guess you could say of
data
um and the way to create better ai is to
have more data that's being constantly
fed into this artificial
intelligence uh algorithm basically how
is crime how is
crime dealt with in a smart city
well uh one of the companies that plans
to deal with crime in a smart city is
called carbine 9-1-1 which you may have
heard of because jeffrey epstein
invested in it but it's uh
also invested in by r.i.p jeffrey
right and basically carbine 911 it's
basically a ninth to replace the 911
call system in the us but what they
envision
is that eventually people won't be
calling 911 anymore the smart city
or different objects will call emergency
services for you
if they determine that there is
something uh wrong in a particular
situation or in your home
or wherever any of the stuff is it's
basically you know a push for the
elimination of privacy
and uh but even before you know smart
cities are
are you know fully uh functional or
established in the us
carbon 911 has a predictive policing
component
basically what it does is that when you
call um
a 911 call center that uses it with your
phone it pulls all of the data off of
your phone
analyzes your past behavior your present
behavior and then extrapolates that to
predict if you will be
the future victim or perpetrator of a
crime
at some point or if you'll be located in
the vicinity where a future crime is
likely to take place which obviously has
super
you know orwellian implications and how
are they judging all the data on your
phone
how is that giving them an idea whether
you're going to be a victim
a perpetrator or in the vicinity of a
crime that's such a wild
idea but i mean it's it's very
interesting right
well you know it's all based on this
this artificial intelligence you know
how it's being trained a lot of these
um algorithms or machine learning
algorithms aren't really transparent
um a lot of them have um have been shown
to have an extreme racial bias uh
whether it's you know
machine learning facial recognition
software for example
uh being racially biased and a lot of
predictive policing programs like the
one that palantir
uh tried to do in in new orleans were
also shown to have a
racial bias so even though a lot of
these people promoting this fourth
industrial revolution stuff say it'll be
more equitable
it'll help fight racial inequities and
all of this stuff a lot of the
technology they're using
in practice has not been shown to do
that so the alexas really are the
beginning when you talk about
you know the internet of things and you
know objects in your house
calling 9-1-1 if they think something's
going wrong
so you know we all of these amazon
alexas i don't but a lot of people do in
their home do you have one ben my
producer
ben has one he has an alexa and uh
get rid of that please well that's all
right my fine my phone's tapped already
if my phone's not tapped they're not
someone up there is asleep
um but the so the amazon alexa is just
the beginning that's kind of preparing
you for
smart products around the house where
will you be talking to everything are
you going to be talking to your
refrigerator
are you going to be talking to
everything pretty soon
well i uh you know that's sort of the
idea so talking about amazon's alexa
right
amazon just put out a new wearable i
forget what it's called but basically
not only does it um
make a 3d model of your body
um and all of this stuff but it also
gauges your emotion during the day oh
you sounded sad today
oh you didn't like you know between 2
and 3 p.m you sounded depressed or at
this period you sounded happy when this
happened and all of this stuff uh
i don't really want to be giving you
know personally i wouldn't want to be
giving jeff bezos
uh the world's richest man that kind of
information about me
and you know it also has you're wearing
it so it has a microphone it records
everything you say everything that
people around you are saying
um you may think that it's for your
convenience it'll help you get more
i don't know i guess fit right you know
it's a lot of how these wearables are
being sold sort of as fitness devices
but they're also surveillance devices
yeah is this the end of humanity and
this is the beginning of us fusing with
machines and is there anything
that can be done to stop that from
happening because that's what i'm
hearing when you
come on and we have these discussions it
sounds like
basically this is the beginning of
us merging with ai to become
some type of superhuman
well yeah uh so unfortunately um
you know obviously i'm a big critic of
of this type of stuff but if you look at
things like the fourth industrial
revolution in the world economic forum
and all of that stuff essentially what
the fourth industrial revolution is is
not just an automation of the economy
and also introducing ai into the economy
it's essentially merging the natural and
digital worlds
and now uh we're hearing more and more
not just about the internet of things
but the so-called internet of
bodies that through wearables and other
advances in this technology that people
will be increasingly connected
to this you know extreme connectivity
that does sort of merge
humans and machines and it's really no
coincidence that a lot of these people
identify as transhumanists
um that's also true for silicon valley
for example like at google
they employ futurists like ray kurzweil
who's probably one of the best known
uh transhumanist uh supporters who think
that
it's the pinnacle of human evolution to
merge with machines
um the question that the issue is is
that like i was saying earlier
a lot of these very powerful individuals
think it's necessary for
the only way for the us to maintain
military and economic hegemony is to
implement the stuff farther than anyone
else has done up to this point it's the
only way to have our ai
be number one because that's where
they're saying the economy is going and
it's the next industrial revolution so
to be the market leader
and you know for national security
purposes we have to be there first this
should really alarm a lot of americans
because when it comes down to economic
hegemony and military hegemony
these people do not care what regular
americans have to say about that they're
not going to put this to a vote they're
not going to ask people's opinion you
know they
it's market leader at all costs they're
going to invade other countries to prop
up the petro dollar
iraq and stuff like that so they're not
going to ask you know
regular americans opinion if they want
this implemented well here's the other
question what are they going to do with
regular americans because
regular people that work at walmart are
not going to get they're not going to
merge with machines
so what's going to happen to all these
people when we have ai doing all of
these jobs
what is going to happen to the millions
and millions hundreds of millions of
people
that are not highly skilled that do not
have the resources the money the
political clout
what is going to happen to them i mean
is there is there any talk about what
happens
to the poor the middle class the
uh the the people that are not you know
considered elite
or essential like when when when eric
schmidt or whoever goes
most work in the future is going to be
done with ai what do we do with all the
other human beings
well uh basically you know there's a lot
of talk from these people
the world economic forum which by the
way is all billionaires a lot of very
predatory billionaires and so-called
vulture capitalists you know compose the
world economic forum
uh they do not uh really give a crap
about regular people even though they
like to cloak
a lot of their initiatives and words
like sustainability and equality and all
of this stuff
basically what they aim to do is create
one large underclass what i would refer
to really is
neo-feudalism powered by you know all of
this technology because really the only
way such a few number of people can keep
the masses
under control is by technological means
basically through the creation of a
panopticon
and um it's really no coincidence you
see companies like palantir promoting
that sort of
um ideology as it was originally
developed the idea of the panopticon
is to have people being constantly
surveilled they don't know if someone's
listening into them or not
but their concern or their fear that
someone is listening
induces in them a subservient obedient
behavior
and they begin to internalize that
behavior and then they just
obey authority i mean that's basically
the the idea behind this
and so that's sort of why they're doing
it and if you think about it the only
way for those people to maintain
uh this extreme inequity that we see in
the u.s now for example
is for them to implement some sort of
system like this
and they know that especially now
because of what's gone on especially
over the course of this year
those inequities are worse than ever and
at some point people will rise up and
ask for a bigger piece of the pie
so these people are thinking how to
prevent that from happening and a lot of
that has to do with the implementation
of these
orwellian surveillance technologies
which by the way
uh the national security state tried to
implement a lot of this after 9 11 but
were unsuccessful in doing so
there was a program they tried to
implement that was being overseen
originally by darpa
called total information awareness and
basically there was push back from
groups like the aclu and even mainstream
media saying that this would erode and
eliminate privacy in the united states
and they ended up shutting it down
officially but those programs got
divided up and went to different
agencies like the nsa
and dhs and all of this and now under
the guise of coronavirus a lot of these
are coming back and if you actually go
to places like the world economic
forum's own website they talk about how
uh in 2030 in the future there will be
no privacy anymore well that's the
article
i was just going to ask you about that
so there's an article on the world
economic forum which uh is amazing and i
have it on my instagram
and my producer's bringing it up it's on
my instagram story
uh where i said we were talking to you
and everybody was very excited
uh there's an article in the world
economic forum and this was somebody
that writes for the world economic
forum and the title of the article was
welcome to 2030 i own nothing
have no privacy and life has never been
better
and it is somebody detailing what
they imagine life is going to be like in
and uh get that article up ben's going
to get that article up
the quotes from the article are are
pretty astounding about
you know how we we don't you know we and
there's a lot of what you talked about
the last time you were on the show it's
like
we don't have shopping anymore and uh
you know
we don't really nobody works that much
the majority of the work is done by ai
and um and you know we're happy
we don't own anything and we have no
privacy it's pretty haunting
here are some quotes which are are
pretty haunting
he goes you know welcome to my city or
should i say our city i don't own
anything i don't own a car don't own a
house i don't own any appliances or any
clothes
it may seem odd to you but it makes
perfect sense for us in the city
everything you consider the product
has now become a service we have access
to transportation accommodation food and
all the things we need in our daily
lives
one by one all these things became free
so it ended up not making sense for us
to own much
again it all seems lovely but when then
you think about
then you are also on the grid you have
no
freedom your life is programmed for you
by people and basically this person who
wrote at the end they made a little uh
thing and they said well this is i'm
imagining what the future is for better
or for worse
um they said first communication became
digitized and free
then clean energy became free things
started to move quickly transportation
dropped dramatically
it made no sense for us to own cars
driverless vehicles
you know um environmental problems seem
far away
um you know when products are turned
into services nobody has an interest in
things with a short lifespan
so everything's designed for durability
repairability recyclability
the death of shopping i can't remember
what this is for most of us
it has been turned into choosing things
to use some of it i find fun
some of it i just want the algorithm to
do for you um and then they went out and
said my biggest concern
is for all the people who do not live in
our city those we lost on the way those
who decided
that it became too much all this
technology those who felt obsolete and
useless when robots in ar took over big
parts of our jobs
those who got upset with the political
system and turned against it they live
different kinds of lives outside of the
city
so again this is really everything
you're talking about about these smart
cities
where everything is provided for you and
you have no freedom
here's one that i love this is
terrifying quote
once in a while i get annoyed about the
fact that i have no real privacy
know where i can go and not be
registered i know that somewhere
everything i do
think and dream is being recorded i just
hope no one will use it against me
wow and that's someone imagining the
future and by the way
not the distant future 20 30.
20 30. 10 years from now everything you
think
say will be recorded hopefully nobody
uses it against me
and i don't own anything nothing is mine
and i have no privacy is this what they
want
uh yeah i mean i would definitely argue
that that's the case
because you know um if you go back and
you look at the history
of of the u.s power establishment we're
broadly speaking i guess the western
power establishment
there is this view that the masses are
dangerous that they're
they give in to animalistic desires and
things like this
a lot of us you can see um from the
father of u.s propaganda himself edward
bernays who was a nephew
my nephew i believe he was the nephew
anyway of uh sigmund freud and basically
used freudian psychology
and applied it to the psychology of the
masses to manipulate the masses on
behalf of both government
um and also corporations and now we're
at a point essentially like i was saying
earlier a lot of these corporations have
essentially murdered like silicon valley
corporations
um have merged with the state and you
know this type of ideology that
the the masses give in to their b steel
animal driven desires and they have to
be controlled by people who are smarter
the elite i mean that's basically the
basis of this whole technocracy idea
is that there needs to be an elite um
who who are better suited for their
opinion obviously
better suited to drive uh the direction
of society and that people
uh the va the masses or whatever
shouldn't really have
or ease should be guided by them and
should not really be able to make their
own decisions about how their lives
are lived and so basically uh this is
just
the logical conclusion of that type of
thinking which has really been pervasive
um in the us and uk and in other western
countries and those powers
is there any way to stop this in motion
is there any way to
fight back against it yeah uh
one deprive these people of your data uh
stars
that's hard you have an alexa in your
house uh
don't do it yeah you know i mean there's
some things that you don't really need
um
you know i mean obviously for some
people they have to have smartphones and
stuff
but you can always use like i don't know
a burner phone when you go out and keep
your smartphone at your house
deprive them of your location data at
least but things like alexa and the
wearables and all of that stuff that is
a really slippery slope
uh in my opinion but beyond that i think
really the best way to beat this
is to not buy into this to what they're
trying to do now at this election where
they're trying to have us at each
other's throats and then we're ignoring
these people uh when really people on
the right
are opposed to this agenda and people on
the left i mean these are the the
predatory billionaires that progressives
are usually railing against but this is
what you know the type of world they
want to create happened
on the left that the left became
fans of the cia and silicon valley
and it because it became this rabid
identity politics where as long
as somebody was the right gender or the
right color
that whatever the message didn't matter
it seems like
as long as it's kamala harris kamala
harris as long as it's
uh when what happened where
the progressive just meant delivering
because progressive now to me
seems like it's just delivering people
to the doorstep
of this this technocracy is what it
really feels like
they are the ones railing for speech
restrictions you know
a lot of people on the left are railing
for the restrictions of speech online
they want to get people the platform
they want people to not
earn any money they want people to be
regulated
they want people to be watched what
happened
how did they get the left which when i
was growing up during bush
the left was the one saying we shouldn't
be going to war
we shouldn't be monitored we shouldn't
have an
oligarchy and why now does the left
seem to accept all of that
um well i think a lot of this started to
happen during the obama year
specifically and a lot of hopes for
reversal of bush era policies were
placed on obama
and then obviously he continued a lot of
those policies but then the focus became
by and large in identity politics and
you were told in a lot of cases you
couldn't criticize obama because he was
a person of color and things like that
that it was racist
to criticize obama-era policies which is
just ludicrous
if you bother to think about it but i
really think most of the damage was done
after the 2016 election particularly
under the guise of russiagate
where we saw people like former c like
cia directors themselves being added to
you know left-leaning cable news
channels to deliver
people on the left the news themselves
so you don't even need things
like operation mockingbird and things
like that where the cia would compromise
or utilize journalists you have the cia
directors themselves marching out and
telling the public what to do yes
it's like operation mockingbird how
quaint it's like now we just have john
brennan on morning joe
just pull up a chair here's some coffee
and tell us whatever horse [ __ ] you want
to tell us for an hour
yeah well like on msnbc you have like
the the daughter
of uh brzezinski who was national
security advisor under jimmy carter who
was over
oversaw operation cyclone which created
al qaeda
right right and it was involved a lot of
very uh controversial things
um and a lot of these agendas that we're
seeing play out now he was involved in
setting the foundations for that and now
she's you know
a major talking head on on the left
network right but at the same time um
you know
there's a lot of censorship in
independent media and alternative media
done by the silicon
silicon valley platforms and they they
definitely censor people on the right
but also on the left and a lot of the
ones they censor on the left are
actual progressives that have attempted
to you know
carry the torch of the ones you know in
the bush era you know cindy sheehan for
example
who was a really famous anti-war
protester during the the bush
administration
um you know she's still around and has a
podcast and all of this stuff but you
never hear about her anymore
and she's still saying the same stuff
and promoting the same policy she was
promoting then
but unfortunately you know in in
establishment left
media discourse today i mean you don't
really see uh
voices like hers elevated anymore
instead you see you know people like
russia gators or
people like rachel maddow uh and on all
that stuff those are supposed to be the
the thought leaders
of the left right where is justlane
maxwell and why is she not
what's going on there why is she not why
why is there no trial
is this because of covid well they post
up remember they pushed off the trial
until like next july
and who knows what state the u.s will be
in then
if they'll even be a trial i think
that's really convenient
um you know i i think also just because
of everything that's going on no one's
really paying attention to epstein news
anymore
like bill barr just came out and found
no wrong doing
uh in the uh with alex acosta and the
sweetheart deal
and it's worth pointing out that bill
barr used to be at the same law firm as
epstein's defense lawyers
and then the whole issue of his dad
having hired epstein at the dalton
school and all of this stuff
yeah and you know there were still
people in the pro-trump wing saying that
bill barr is going to fight the deep
state and here he goes being like
nothing was done wrong in the
epstein-sweetheart deal
what do you who do you think q anon is
if you had to speculate as to that
who is q anon or what is q and i mean we
know it's some
kind of troll operation at this point
you know i mean what do you think it is
do you think there was any truth to it
at any point or
was it always kind of trolling i mean it
seems to
be a bit you know it's clearly over the
top and ridiculous they also
you know it's kind of like you know they
keep stringing these desperate people
along that there's going to be some
big event coming and nothing can stop
what's happening and everyone's going to
jail and just you wait and see and
trust the plan and everything like that
what do you what do you what do you
think this is
i think it's a i think it's a u.s driven
intelligence psyop
um and i think basically the target of
it is to have uh
you know a demographic that would
normally be most vocal
against uh perceived government tyranny
uh people on the right gun owners things
like that
um basically to have them completely
docile sitting there being like
yeah we'll just trust the plan and it'll
all work out and even in some cases
you've had q anon cheer on regime change
in iran were with iran
uh martial law being declared um things
like that when these people before would
have opposed those things and it's worth
pointing out that really the roadmap for
q anon
was a was originally developed by a um
an
obama advisor named cass sunstein who
now is advising the the world health
organization about its vaccine global
vaccine agenda
uh for covid19 but cass on steen during
the obama administration he wrote about
the need to influence for the government
to infiltrate conspiracy movements
in order to reverse the general trend of
conspiracy movements fostering a
distrust in the government and to
instead foster a love and trust of
government
so then you have q anon pop-up and it's
oh we love
trump we love the president we love john
bolton
we love sessions and all of these people
who were
obvious establishment swamp monsters to
use you know trump vernacular or
whatever
um you know put all your faith in people
like that when john bolton is like the
most insane
like crazy neocon guy you're going to
put his your trust in him that he's
going to end the wars you know
yeah i just it's so amazing to watch
these guys even after you know
this we have this election and you know
they're still up there going trust the
plan
don't worry about it i mean it seems
just like a grift i mean it's clearly a
grift
yeah but so here's the thing with q anon
too kiwi non was basically designed to
be a giant straw man
where everything that is uh bad
now they're saying all these
conspiracies that are inconvenient right
now are merging with kiwi on and that
includes people like robert f kennedy jr
from children's health defense
which are critics of of the
pharmaceutical industry and the vaccine
industry in general
you know there's the washington post
coming out saying that they're merging
with q
anon with no actual basis but they write
a whole article about
how uh people that um you know promote
vaccine hesitancy like robert f kennedy
jr are national security threats
and you had q the fbi come out last year
saying q anon is a domestic terror
threat and all of this stuff and now
they're trying to link people that are
critical of the pharmaceutical industry
right now they're treating enemies of
corporations like enemies of the state
q a is a great whipping boy for a lot of
people that just want to get
inconvenient questions about
certain government policies and certain
people or epstein or epstein or any of
that stuff
what do you think uh is going to happen
with the new coronavirus lockdowns which
are
certainly on their way um yeah i think
it's going to be
really not good um you know all we have
to do is just really look at a lot of uh
you know the biden transition team i
guess you could say in what what they
plan to do with coronavirus and also the
fact that biden's
transition team has adopted the the
phrase build back better which we've
also seen used
uh in canada and the uk and all of these
places which come straight from the
world economic forum and this whole push
for a fourth industrial revolution
these lockdowns what they end up doing
is forcing the closure of small
businesses and medium-sized businesses
um giving the vast majority of what was
once their business to giant
corporations like amazon for example and
in furthering this push of buying
everything online
uh having shop have everything be either
mobile app based
um or or internet based and sort of uh
promoting more of this contactless
humanless uh
you know uh technology-based society um
that's basically
what a lot of these lockdowns have ended
up uh engendering and also creating a
very um
you know uh impoverished population
really exacerbating a lot of economic
issues that existed before
coronavirus but i mean it's just
absolutely outrageous
that you had supposed coronavirus relief
bills past the beginning of this year
and they were given to hedge funds like
blackrock to throw that money around and
a lot of these loans that were supposed
to be for small businesses and it
actually go to small businesses
and so you know we're at a point where
we're going to have millions of
americans be evicted
soon if there isn't some sort of relief
bill passed and nothing appears to be
happening on that front and that is
really
um really alarming and the fact that
politicians on
in neither party you're really talking
about these issues
um is is is just very disconcerting
and um you know i'm really honestly
worried um about what's going to go down
in the united states in the next few
months
what do you think about because they've
been i'm sorry well i was just going to
say about these evictions
that are coming uh and the looming
crisis that people have in terms of
um rent what has there been anything
that you've picked up on
in terms of like is there any plan to
whether it's at nefarious or not is
there any plan to deal with that because
that's a common catastrophe
right well uh what's interesting to me
is that some silicon valley billionaires
have been
uh basically promoting this this plan
where they're going to have uh
new homes set up for the homeless but
they're going to be smart homes
right and they're going to and you have
a lot of these same silicon valley
billionaires like jack dorsey of twitter
for example
uh promoting ubi and things like that
and ubi recently has become you know
a popular progressive policy but it was
actually originally
proposed by the father of neoliberalism
milton friedman himself
and it's also promoted by the world
economic forum as a way
to further the automation of society and
basically you know ubi
if everything is automated and done by
article and artificial intelligence and
you have a ubi well you don't really
make much more money than
the ubi it's not a universal basic
income it's the universal income period
it's not a basic income you can't really
supplement it with everything
with anything what do you want to employ
are you going to moonlight is it an
assistant to a robot
yeah it's a tough thing you know i i'm
i'm on
i'm i'm i'm not excited about all this i
don't know how much i could do about it
but
i'm certainly not excited about what is
coming and
it sounds like sooner rather than later
um
what do you think would be the way to
handle the coronavirus would it be to
just kind of basically
say you know distancing and blah blah
blah
what what what what level of scam are we
dealing with here it is a real virus
people do get sick some of them die
but what do we what do we think what
would we do what's the way to handle
this
have other countries done it better what
what's the way to kind of handle this
without
you know getting rid of human beings
getting rid of humanity
uh well i mean that that's there's a lot
of different i'm i'm
probably not like uh right you know an
epidemiologist or an infectious disease
expert
um or whatever but i mean there's
definitely things we've been doing that
have not been working and it's worth
pointing out that now
right before you know traditional flu
season
you have the cdc saying quietly saying
that they're going to stop
collecting you know influenza death data
and basically saying that regular flu
deaths are going to be lumped in with
covides now
which obviously is going to over you
know overly inflate things but beyond
that uh something that's been
really disconcerting in my opinion is
this shift away from talking about
deaths and hospitalizations and talking
just about cases
and if you look at a lot of this these
claims that we're facing a dark winter
we have to lock down on all of the stuff
it's all just about the number of cases
a lot of which can be as symptomatic
they're not necessarily people with
symptoms that have to be hospitalized
and if you look
at you know the number of cases compared
to hospitalizations and deaths it really
doesn't add up in in
you know i don't really think a second
lockdown uh
is really justified and you also have to
take into consideration too that you
know a lot of this just
these desperate circumstances people are
being forced into economically
have an impact on people's well-being um
and also mental health i mean suicides
are going way up too because people
can't
be with their families they can't
socially interact
normally uh they're losing jobs a lot of
people are drowning in debt and don't
have a way out or they're going to be
evicted soon
you know a lot of these things are not
being taken in into consideration really
at all
and since we have such a very powerful
lobby like the world economic forum
really pushing for a lot of these
policies
because they want to remake and rebuild
the great reset
as they call it you know they basically
need
uh to do a controlled demolition of a
lot of different aspects of our society
in order to rebuild it
build back better they say in a way um
final question the problem is oh sorry
no it's okay it's okay we love we love
how knowledgeable you are
do you think biden gets inaugurated do
you think uh or do you think we just are
we're entering some weird period of
legal challenges and court problems and
how long does this
go on do you think um i think it's
definitely going to go on a while longer
i don't really know what's going to
happen in january to be honest there's a
lot of different things that are
that are going on right now we probably
won't have a lot of
resolution in terms of the election at
least until the electoral college votes
in mid-december but it could be in
january when there's that first session
of congress
um or even inauguration day itself you
know there's a lot of uh
there's been speculation that there may
be no president-elect on inauguration
day
some of these groups that were gaming
out different scenarios for chaos
uh uh for the election well before the
election took place
uh like the transition integrity project
uh had several scenarios that they
gained out and this
this isn't these aren't just like
anybody right i mean these are like uh
very prominent republicans and very
prominent democrats gaming this stuff
out
together um in in june of this year they
had several scenarios where there was no
president-elect in january and they
hinted about
maybe the military will have to step in
wow
who's doing that who's putting these uh
models together and who's running these
simulations
uh well that was the the one i'm talking
about there were actually several groups
that were doing simulations um but the
one i just mentioned was
the transition integrity project and in
that case the person that was playing
joe biden in those scenarios was john
podesta
who is hillary clinton's former campaign
manager but you had really prominent
republicans uh
former chairs of the republican national
committee like michael steele you've had
former
heads of the department of defense
former heads of department of homeland
security
um the two people that created that um
one is rosa brooks and nils gilman
they're both very much tied to a lot of
these silicon valley billionaires
rosa brooks works for the new america
foundation which is a think tank that's
funded by bill gates and eric schmidt
uh reid hoffman and pierre mittier are
all silicon valley billionaires
nils gilman is part of the gruen
institute which is trying to build a
transnational
uh group of experts and politicians and
other figures to sort of usher in this
fourth industrial revolution
are these simulations are they
simulations
um are they every four years or is this
like a new one though like what if
it was a new thing oh no specific to
this election yeah
in june what if we don't have a
president and they said maybe the
military would step in
yeah and what's weird is that one of the
ladies that founded the lady that
co-founded this rosa brooks her research
area is the
murky line between military and police
uh in war zones and things like that and
they were basically gaming out scenarios
uh
where you know the military may have to
step in and all of that stuff and what's
very alarming is that you know the more
chaos that ends up taking place in this
post-election period
the more the federal government can
swoop in and justify uh
maximum order right as the antidote to
maximum chaos
yeah i mean it's it's terrifying quick
before you go what is the anthrax story
from 2001 because i remember that
i remember how absurd it is and i want
you to just go into that just while i
have you here what
is the anthrax story because i remember
how absurd
and ridiculous that was they all pinned
it on one guy and
yeah well so uh that's not an easy
that's not a quick
uh thing to answer and it's actually
really important uh
to go over it so um give me a little bit
here
because one of the things we've been
hearing a buzzword we've been hearing a
lot lately
is dark winter right right it's gonna be
a dark winter darkest winter
and all of that well in june 2001 there
was a bioterror simulation
by what is now the johns hopkins center
for health security which also did event
201 last year
and things like that and it was called
dark winter and it included former cia
directors former fbi directors
and a lot of other prominent national
security officials um and predicted a
lot of things that would later come to
take place
just a couple months later during the
anthrax attacks including anthrax being
sent
through the mail that anthrax letters
would be received by members of the
media
and also the initial narrative of the
bio terror attack itself which was that
saddam hussein was working with al-qaeda
to enact bio-terror
uh a bioterror attack on the u.s this
was all gamed out in june 2001 and then
the anthrax attacks are revealed to the
public in october 2001
and that was the initial narrative that
it was gonna that it was uh
anthrax from iraq um and that al qaeda
had been involved in all of this stuff
uh of course it later was revealed that
the anthrax used in the attacks was a a
strain exclusive to the us military and
had to have come from either a u.s
military lab
or a u.s military contractor so the
whole narrative that it must have been
iraq and al qaeda eventually started to
fall apart
but a lot of people that had been
involved in dark winter uh tried to run
with that narrative for as long as
possible and what's also important
is that in the period between september
11th and when the anthrox attacks
actually took place
a lot of these people that had been
involved in dark winter like jerome
howard for example
had a apparent foreknowledge that
anthrax was going to take place so you
have for example
jerome howard on the day of 9 11 uh
telling people
that they need to start taking uh an
antibiotic to prevent anthrax infection
this was going on at dick cheney's
office
uh in in particular and then just a
couple days after 9 11 dick cheney was
personally briefed
by the people that created the dark
winter exercise about dark winter
um and all of this stuff and then you
have a bunch of the project for a new
american century think tank neocons
of which dick cheney and donald rumsfeld
were members going on national media
saying anthrax talking about anthrax
constantly you also had a member of the
media that was at dark winter
judith miller uh being involved in
writing several articles
between september 11th and when the
anthrax attacks took place
talking about how uh talking about
anthrax and bioterror al qaeda and
anthrax and all of this stuff sort of
seeding this narrative and those attacks
end up
uh taking place and what's really crazy
too
about anthrax is the fbi investigation
itself which was called amerithrax
um it took them almost a decade to
officially close that case it's been he
it was hugely
criticized not just by people uh at the
national academy of sciences
but also by one of the lead
investigators of the investigation for
the fbi itself their lead investigator
richard lambert
actually ended up filing a whistleblower
lawsuit saying that the fbi's
investigation into the anthrax attacks
was a giant cover-up
and that's from the guy that was
investigating it for the fbi itself
they pinned it on bruce ivins before
they could take it to trial bruce ivan's
committed suicide
even though he was under 24 7 fbi
surveillance uh
and so they didn't actually have to
prove their case against him in court
because he uh conveniently dies right
before they take it to trial
and uh you know really i would argue the
anthrax uh
attacks remain unsolved but if you
actually look into some of the
companies uh that stood to benefit most
from anthrax and what they were doing at
the time it's very
revealing about some possible motives
and that is very alarming and i don't
know if you want me to go into this
time but the company that uh
gained the most from the anthrax attacks
which was called bioport at the time
they're now called emergent biosolutions
they're actually manufacturing the coven
19 vaccine
for operation warp speed fun
yeah so these anthrax attacks could be
they could have been just like a false
flag to like
let's get us into iraq quicker
let's start tying the narrative mass
destruction thing
right the big event of 9 11 but then it
was a lot of the anthrax
fear that uh conditioned people to think
oh
the uh terrorism is gonna be a way of
life
yeah bioterrorism yeah it wasn't enough
911 we needed the bioterrorism angle i
remember
time magazine the the sarin gas
you know the the japan the photos like
they were really pushing that narrative
hard and the anthrax right and a lot of
very prominent people involved uh with
the cover-up of the anthrax attacks and
in in
very uh shady positions in the lead up
to those attacks are also very
involved in covid19 response right now
right
one of them is the guy that uh was also
very intimately involved
in the dark winter exercise his name is
robert cadlick uh
he's currently the assistant secretary
for preparedness and response at hhs and
managing covid19 response
on behalf of hhs and he's the guy that
gave the covid19 vaccine a complete
liability anyone that administers or
manufactures that vaccine can't be
liable
in emergent biosolutions the company i
mentioned earlier he used to be a
lobbyist for them
and has been just involved in a lot of
really crazy stuff over the the past
couple years basically
um you know huge conflicts of interest
with that particular company which has
very shady ties to the 2001 anthrax
attacks how is the country that you're
in doing with covet 19
oh it's a mess well i mean chile's a u.s
client state so i mean it's basically
following a similar
uh playbook but it's it's a lot more
draconian than even what's going on in
the u.s and that's because after the
um 1973 coup
backed by the cia and henry kissinger
that installed pinochet
the pinochet dictatorship in chile it's
basically been used as a laboratory
uh by the u.s power structure for
different things whether it's
neoliberalism for example was
essentially born in chile they say
because they use it as a giant
laboratory for that
but also i would argue some of the more
draconian equivalent 19 responses
that we may see in the next couple of
weeks in different states in the u.s
you know had they been piloting some of
that out here so since march for example
there's been curfews in chile
they have a five-phase uh lockdown
system where they constantly move
uh cities back into lockdown uh based on
you know faulty data i would argue
because the
the minister of health admitted that he
was making up numbers uh
not that long ago uh after he resigned
he was pretty blatant about it because
you know
uh there's no accountability really in
chile like the us but i would argue
would you ever would you ever come back
to america to get assassinated
um i'd have to think about it i don't
know i mean i have a toddler too so i
mean just even the idea of getting on a
plane with a little kid
and have to make her wear a mask the
whole time for an overnight flight i
it doesn't really it's an appeal but you
got to go on a book tour if you finish
yeah you got to go on a book tour
well if america still left i'll think
about it we'll see
if if america's not left i don't think
chile will be left
either but who knows maybe you got maybe
he's right whitney webb
thank you so much you're always great we
always appreciate you
coming on um you know you're
you're you're you're really a
thought-provoking
great writer any pieces you're working
on now that are coming out you want to
tease anything
uh sure yeah i'm going to have some
reports uh coming out next week about
operation warp speed which is something
a lot of people have declined to report
on because it's controversial but it's
worth pointing out that this is supposed
to be the official covet 19 vaccination
program for the us government
it's being run by the military top fda
officials are barred from attending
meetings even sitting in on meetings
about it let alone participating
which is pretty insane uh you also have
dhs
the nsa and the fbi are part of
operation wart speed
google oracle palantir are part of this
thing
uh it's being led by a uh a former vice
president for glaxosmithkline whose big
obsession is bioelectronic medicine
uh there's definitely a lot of red flags
about it but specifically my article um
next week is going to be about
palantir's role in it and
how they're planning not to just take
the first vaccine that's approved
and make that the vaccine for everyone
they're planning to uh
all six of the vaccine candidates
they're assuming will be approved and
they're going to assign each one
to a different critical population which
seems a little weird
given past uh vaccination campaigns that
the us government has sponsored
um and what's really alarming as i
mentioned earlier
you know google's part of operation warp
speed but they also control youtube and
they put out this policy recently where
if you ask questions about operation
warp speed
or covid19 uh vaccines in general which
by the way you're all using
the ones in operation warp speed anyway
are all using a
vaccine technology that's never been
licensed or taken to market before
so if you have concerns about it being
rushed and there not being enough safety
trials and things like that google can
de-platform you on youtube now i would
argue that's a big conflict of interest
so unfortunately because of that a lot
of people
and independent media even because you
know a lot of their business models
might depend on monetization on youtube
and stuff aren't talking about this
thing
but you know i mean it's a big uh
they're planning to
inject it into you know give it to 300
million americans by january 2021 so
it's definitely something that can have
big implications
so um january 2021 you mean a year
from now no no in january this january
in a couple months
in a couple of months they plan to get
it get
get everybody vaccinated well most
everybody
300 million i think the population's
slightly higher but yeah it's definitely
concerning especially considering that
we have the pfizer vaccine
is supposed to be the first one that's
going to be approved and one of the top
people at the fda the head for the
center for drug evaluation and research
is a former pfizer vice president for
product safety
that covered up the ties of a pfizer
product zoloft to birth defects and
pfizer tried to keep her from
testifying under oath about that and so
now she's one of the people that's going
to be rubber stamping pfizers at covet
19 vaccine that they've already
started producing hundreds and thousands
of doses for before it's even approved
and have sold doses
uh to different governments around the
world funny we can we can all
we can all uh you know the sackler
family is like the approved there's
always an approved
it's like made off you know made off
they're like you could say made of
a scumbag but don't talk about anyone
else so the sackler family's like
they're
bad they made oxycontin but every other
pharmaceutical company it's like
they're great they're just a benevolent
force of good and
they just want to help out and they want
to medicate all your kids visor has paid
billions of dollars in fines over the
years for like illegal marketing
promoting their products for
experimental off-label uses they
did an illegal drug experimentation
trial
in nigeria that killed 11 kids and then
tried to bribe nigerian officials to
cover it up
and all we heard about when they had
their uh their self-reported results
saying that it's not their vaccine's 90
effective just pure positive press i
mean no one's asking questions
of these pharmaceutical giants that have
been given billions of dollars
to develop these vaccines as as they
choose with experimental technologies
like mrna and dna vaccines that have
very limited safety profiles and humans
they skipped animal trials for these
um and the fact that we can't ask
questions about these um
you know these companies track records
when you know pharmaceutical companies
have never been held accountable
for a lot of their horrible crimes just
like most other corporations in the u.s
so the fact that we you know
the answer would be to uh have more
transparency but the
operation warp speed is insanely
secretive they didn't even want to
release the contracts with vaccine
companies
um but they had to get letters from
people in congress and things like that
to do so
um and you know uh they ended up
releasing them and they were mostly uh
redacted
uh and we're having you know groups like
palantir deciding who gets what vaccine
uh palantir was basically started by the
cia
i mean that doesn't really uh make me
feel any better you know what i mean
the fact they want to censor people uh
for asking questions about it instead of
answering those questions in good faith
or maybe
not barring top fda officials from even
sitting in in their meetings
uh you know i mean maybe that would be
the answer because this is something
that's being made for
americans in peacetime why is the
military running it
why isn't the cdc and fda running it uh
it's completely dominated by the
military the leadership of this thing
yeah all good questions all terrifying
questions and and all answers that you
we probably don't even want to know the
answers to but we need to know the
answers to them whitney webb
go to her patreon at whitneywebmpn
go to her rockfin channel which is a
youtube alternative
also go find her work on uh last
american vagabond
uh yeah i a lot of my warp speed
reporting has been published there so
you can still find some of my work on
there
go find her stuff and then buy her book
when it comes
out i don't know when you're planning on
putting that out or
uh next june it comes out yeah well this
is uh
as always a lot of fun a lot of reasons
not to sleep and uh
you know by 2030 everybody you won't own
anything you won't have a car you won't
have any
freedom you won't have any choice but
apparently life will be great according
to the world economic forum
according to the billionaires at the
world economic forum
yeah well you won't own anything but the
billionaires will own everything they'll
own it all
and you'll rent it from them they'll oh
no the only thing you'll own is your
your little vaccine chip that's the only
thing you'll own
winnie webb thank you for coming on i
appreciate it you're the best
thanks anytime tim thank you